do you understand that if I told you if
I took this moment for all hundred-plus
of us and went back 15 years from that
ago and said let me show you what you're
going to be doing exactly 15 years from
today we would all be like holy [ __ ]
[Music]
morning vaynernation we haven't been
doing dailyvee we started the led right
after football season so I guess this is
a good time for a public service
announcement which is please take all my
monday interactions after Jeff losses
with sub level of context you know it's
funny I talk so high level don't let the
little things but it's amazing what the
passion of escapism means for me the
Jets is like the one place in the world
that I don't have perspective that I'm
allowed to escape and it like takes me
away from all my realities and it's
actually stunningly relaxing even though
I seemed quite wound up and pissed but
you know the boy yesterday was tough
Congrats all the Bengal fans happy for
you guys it's a franchise that has some
won a Super Bowl either ever and has a
and we have a 1:1 since 1969 and Jets
beat the Bengals in a huge playoff game
several years ago not that long ago
actually 2009 and I went there and the
fans were gracious and so I have a lot
of respect plus my friend Nate my friend
Ian good Bengal fans so I'm never happy
for anybody but at least I could be
somewhat respectful
never happened for anybody in football
yeah you know what's so weird I'm almost
like the bizarro version of myself in
football I'm like literally that polar
opposite
anyway I'm [ __ ] crushed thank you
saltiest [ __ ] this morning huge Jets
loss to copy winning a chance like
Marriott and Hilton should have created
Airbnb you know like all those taxi
medallion people they should have
created rumor the perp the person that's
getting disrupted out borders and Barnes
& Nobles was in a much better place than
Amazon to become Amazon you know but
they don't want him
[Music]
on this episode I'm in a salty mood as a
Jets lost you know what happens with
salty B is that I eliminate any thought
of entertainment and I just give answers
here's how that gets against this here's
the outside law liability of that and
how is vaynermedia getting reimbursed
for that number or if not what am i
doing with Steve to the death oh it's a
monster difference my man jacket got it
create the ideas then like in a box then
go find something I think another thing
to add and I wonder if you brought this
up again back to like having a similar
vibe the other thing I think about that
I'm gonna bring the table is not only
cuz you can but because the upside so
amazingly outweighs the downside if you
really think about what they spend their
money on putting five or ten or fifteen
million dollars against this initiative
for these brands is nothing yet could be
could be so impactful if you figured it
out like by the way I do think this is a
zero to 100 game like this is super hard
like to me it's like either you figured
it out and you got all the credit and it
all work or it's just something half
pregnant like did nothing and the punch
and the punch line is for them is for
all of them is who's gonna be the first
will because all the value comes from
that you're welcome such a pleasure
but you know if there's a 12 9 year old
me as a kid I would have I would love
right now to be influencing that person
right there there's a lot of young
entrepreneurs and if you're an 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 year-old entrepreneur my
content I want to be at the forefront
and I want to be in your purview and I
want you to know who I am if you are not
waking up every morning and checking the
top 150 free apps on the Apple charts
you're making a huge mistake that's
where Marco Polo caught my attention
actual musically caught my attention
snapchat caught my attention it's a very
simple way for a lot of you to keep up
with where the opportunities are so
instead of having you drink the water to
this question I'm going to show you
where the water is because then you
become media not just somebody within it
just like I did with Wine Library TV I
became the media not just a retailer
selling off the media I think that's a
really good idea America doesn't care
about the mistake America cares about
the cover-up
we're not mad at Samsung for the battery
that goes on fire because all of us who
are even-keeled recognize that sometimes
that happens when you're innovating what
we read hate is a little you know
person's house burns down and Samsung
goes that's not us we hate the cover up
I mean like really like we are forgiving
forgiving nation what we don't want is
any company thinking they're gonna pull
one up over on us it's unbelievably our
visceral to the [ __ ] so I don't
think there's any one-size-fits-all I
would just say the most authentic in the
fastest way possible I think what
excites me most Jen is that this last 10
years for me has been really about
social media the evolution of
communication on the internet what VR
and everything that Elon Musk Zoe's up
to and what Apple's up to an Alexa with
Amazon AI and Pokemon go and filters on
snapchat is wait a minute
this is a next-generation technology
that's coming and I don't know
everything you know the last one was
really good for me because it was about
human communication I believe that to be
true for the next generation but I think
what most excites me is if you're really
paying attention what's happened over
the last year self-driving cars we're
starting to see the real light version
of things that have been talked about
for the last three or four years and I
think we can all agree that ten years
from today the world can be very very
very different do we just take a step
back does anybody understand what's
happening right now to do we're doing
right now which is have three people
doing video interaction with each other
cleaning this is very clean to have how
many of our people watching right now
wherever they are do you understand that
if I told you if I took this moment for
all hundred plus of us and went back 15
years from this ago and said let me show
you what you're gonna be doing exactly
15 years from today we would all be like
holy [ __ ] forget about where we're going
how about just being captivated by the
fact that we're living in this right
this second as you go down this path
this is what's happened to me at some
level you just realize you just kind of
keep saying it and you let the chips
fall where they fall like you know I
this is why winners win and losers lose
like like if you're gonna look for them
know then you'll find the no and you'll
be in the no camp losses and wasted time
are actually wins in the gathering of
context in a world where the value of
knowing has never been greater so let me
say it one more time because I know
there was that was an interesting kind
of like answer I don't think people
realize that doing the work to learn all
these things is a win in itself even if
it doesn't create short-term victories I
I equate it to the following we're
living a digital marathon and most
people aren't willing to get on the
treadmill for a couple of months to get
ready for it
as you loses meaning when you're
backwards and every way to work and ever
meeting race you got you never not
beating
[Music]